all right um welcome to the ddps seminar
everyone uh before we introduce our
invited speaker let's go over some rules
as usual
first of all please mute yourself during
the talk if you have immediate questions
you're welcome to amuse and ask or
otherwise please use the chat room to
post your questions so that we can
address them in the Q a session at the
end
second today's seminar is open to
external audience so no classified
discussion is allowed finally the talk
will be recorded and uploaded to our
YouTube channel now let me introduce our
speaker it is an honor to host Eduardo
gilding who is currently a professor of
petroleum engineering at the Texas A M
University and is the holder of the LF
Peterson 36 professorship in petroleum
engineering he received his PhD from the
Texas at the University of Texas at
Austin in aerospace engineering and has
held postdoctoral positions with Rice
University and UT Austin his research
has been supported by grants from NSF
doe DOD NASA and Industry with main
topics in physics-based and data-driven
reduce order modeling for Reservoir
simulation and optimization
and truly modeling control and
automation it was indented to into the
spe distinguished membership in 2021.
today he will talk about guided deep
learning manifold linearization of
porous media flow equations for digital
twin operations please enjoy the
wonderful talk now with the further deal
then we headed to another building by
asking a random question so where is the
um the place that you like the most in
Brazil
uh I'll I'll say my my home country my
home City Sao Paulo
like four of my patients and sunlights
well well I mean as as people say in
Brazil you gotta go to Rio De Janeiro
during the day and Sao Paulo during the
night
so that's uh oh I see it that's good so
uh yeah the stage is Narrows
okay thanks so much thank you thank you
Tony for the nice introduction thank
everyone for joining my uh my seminar
it's a pleasure and honor to be here in
a you know I've been watching many of
those the ddps seminars myself and I
really liked it and uh you guys are
doing really great on on that Spectrum
um so let me uh talk a little bit about
what I've been doing in the last few
years uh my research on mod reduction
has been going on for many many years
now but uh we are moving a little bit on
the you know trying to put things on the
digital twin perspective
uh and I'm gonna show to you a couple of
things that we are doing uh I'll start
up with a uh the idea of digital twing
at least then uh from a drilling
perspective drilling engineering
perspective that I'm gonna move on to
Reservoir engineering
so that we set the uh this stage for
what I mean by digital twins operation
uh this is a joint work at least on the
the visualizations and the digital twin
framework with the Gentile from the
visualization department and on the uh
um uh you know the uh the the machine
learning scientific machine learning
with the Elisa braganetta from the
electrical engineering here at a m
uh and many other my students uh you
know I you know many of the the work
that I'm gonna be presenting is from
Emilio uh who is now at petrobras in
Brazil Marcelo who is now at Exxon Mobil
uh Narendra that is McKinsey and Enrique
there is a postdoc here and Levi that's
a postdoc as well with Dr braganetto and
uh other students are being been working
on on that okay so um I'm not gonna
spend too much time on uh the the why
we're doing this I think this uh the uh
the seminar series uh the at least from
what we are watching here uh that
explains really well why mod reduction
and other things are important but for
my perspective uh we are going to a new
wave of uh um you know implementations
of porous media flow and then you know
given that uh you know we there's ccos
hydrogen storage uh geothermal and even
hydrocarbon production right uh you know
these not zero emissions uh Paradigm uh
it's important but uh we all know that
uh you know in some ways petroleum
Engineers are on the subsurface and
that's a quote that I get from a faculty
here at a m who is very emerging to a
subsurface as well
um so uh and that's why we're still
keeping the doing what uh what I'm doing
on on the subsurface flows okay but
there is a commonality between all these
issues here and it can be ccos
geothermal hydrocarbon or hydrogen
storage as you may know they all have a
uh you know uncertainty related to
everything not only uh technical
political economical but everything that
we do in that realm right and they all
part of uh you know family of a large
scale simulation problems right we are
using somehow a subscriber face flow
simulation for prediction and they are
computationally expensive right not only
that you know it's not about only
simulating but it's about getting an
answer and an answer meaning a fast and
robust way to obtain an optimized answer
whatever optimize mean I'm not going to
the optimization process itself here in
my talk but now optimization can mean
minimize risks can be increased storage
for CO2 for instance production and
anything that you want but the problem
is that we are calling this simulator
many many times you need a uh you know a
way to to to you know to get a fast
answer out of that okay so that's the
the the the the the idea here and not
only that
one uh interesting article that was
posted in the jpt was you know a couple
of years ago and you can say that it's a
little it's a little bit old yet already
but uh no they they talk a little bit
about uh you know the the one way to
solve the issues
using uh you know moving forward with
this transition it is that we're going
to have to digitize a lot more uh the
the operations of things that we do
nowadays right and then that's why I uh
moved on to a little bit on the
additional twin Concept in energy which
is not new right if you look at uh you
know there was a paper published in 2018
uh that actually talked about the last
10 years you know back then the last 10
years of a digital twin in energy right
and uh you know back then War you know
mostly on replication of platforms and
the operation itself uh
annotated uh
okay so something popped up here from
annotation I don't know what uh what is
that but uh anyway uh uh so so
um
uh no eating for uh turbines and
everything so the the digital twin
concept is not new right so let me show
what that we're actually doing on that
real okay
um the problem that happens in the last
uh you know five ten years is that you
know when I joined a m 13 years ago I
used to see it on the many of the uh
industry uh board uh you know uh
meetings and uh faculty used to complain
a lot that the companies wouldn't give
data right we don't have data we don't
have the data now we have a new problem
right which is that the companies
actually everybody want to give data and
we don't know what to do with that data
so the the old rhetoric that we don't
have enough data may not apply anymore
and you can see that uh you know in
drilling operations you're getting you
know information on the beat and this is
a Halliburton cerebral drill bit that
you can get uh you know accelerometers
and other measurements directly on the
beat with a thousand Hertz of frequency
right so it's a lot of data we have a d
uh you know a distributed acoustic and
distribute temperature sensing that you
have gigabytes of data terabytes of of
data being shipped to the uh along the
well right and we don't know what to do
with this this data right so somehow we
need a some form of a data reduction
model reduction and a combination of
those things to actually Implement
things on the digital twin framework
okay
all right let me let me just give you a
glimpse of one thing that we are doing
on the drilling side then we're going to
move on to the uh Reservoir side and
that's a joint work with the uh Gentile
the one that I mentioned before
um and that while we're trying to do a
digital twin for drilling uh
optimization problems okay
um I'm not going to go into details on
the drilling itself but basically we
have a drilling machine right here and
we still have uh you know the problem is
very complicated prohibitively expensive
uh to simulate everything so what we are
focusing we're focusing on the drill bit
the BHA simulation here okay so for just
think about that we are right at this
tip of this uh the drill bit right and
of course we have data from uh you know
information from logs information from
how the structure of the geological
media works and we're going to try to
employ a digital 20 to recreate the
environment and the platform for for the
drilling Okay so that's uh and as I
mentioned we're going to just focus on
the uh the the BHA right the ph8 so we
are modeling this into this BHA
framework all right so let me show you a
quick video I feed this uh pops up
hopefully it will
of our digital twin implementation for
drilling uh optimization
and that's basically a real time
drilling operation getting real-time
data from a system we have here a
miniaturized drilling machine so that's
why we get the real-time data right but
anyway so the focus here is not drilling
per se so let me just close this and uh
move on hopefully
uh
let me just close this
and move on up on this one
and basically what we implemented here
is a reinforcement learning for uh you
know
trajectory steering on on this drilling
drilling machine okay so there's a paper
coming up but the nice thing about that
we can optimize and everything but as I
said the problem is not drilling per se
and the thing is that uh drilling is
just a small part of this digital twin
operation that we want to do right I'm
going to for the interest of time I'm
gonna come back to this in the end if I
have time I'm going to show the
trajectories like later in the end but
the idea is that
in real-time operations we want to put
together not only the drilling itself
right we want to put together a
reservoir characterization model we want
to put together a fast Reservoir
simulation model and we're going to have
uncertainty associated with that as well
right so it says it's a much more
complicated problem just just going to a
game like and if you look at what we've
done we will use a game uh engine
framework right to develop our uh our
digital twin for for drilling but for
Reservoir that's a different story right
there's a little bit more complication
uh going from a simulation of this this
entire Loop right
um okay so but in my perspective right
we already have something an additional
a reservoir simulator is a digital twin
by by Nature right if you look at what
we are doing in the digital twin right
we are replicating the effect of uh a a
a certain things right with real-time
data and and the problem with a
reservoir simulation to become a digital
twin is exactly that additional twin
requires real-time data integration into
this virtual environment
and if you look at this problem here
this is a Unison Benchmark from a
Brazilian uh University unicamp one can
take a look at but if you look at uh you
know just this small problem here all
right uh we have a uh about uh you know
one billion of states right what I mean
pressures and saturations and
concentrations and so and so forth right
with uh you know if you're gonna
optimize with about 1500 variables to
optimize so we need to do something else
with that uh that simulation to be came
to to be able to do a digital twin
framework and there's enablers that does
that it is exactly model reduction and
data driven modeling at least in my
perspective right so uh so let me let me
let me let me go to that direction now
and let me show what we're doing to do
this mod reduction for reservoir uh
simulation perspective right and I I
know suffice to say that uh you know uh
you know Reservoir simulation is a uh is
a hard thing to do and as I mentioned
you're looking at you know a couple
partial differential equations uh lots
of States variables lots of control
variables and so forth okay
let me just uh you know this slide here
serves for you to know what are the
states that we are looking at pressures
and saturations for this uh Reservoir
okay uh but as far as the output goes
right the one look at uh oil rates uh
water rates that you can do you know CO2
rates and and so forth and usually this
is handled by what's called pisman
equation here it's a semi empirical
equation right here and that's a one
part of the issue that we are going to
try to solve later on in my my slide it
is how we handle actually this output
okay this output would uh you know most
of the model reduction techniques that
are out there they only look at state
right they never looked at the output by
itself and if you're going to couple
days with an Optimizer output is the
most important thing that one has to
look at okay so let's keep that in
perspective all right so what is the
model reduction problem uh modern
reduction problem is actually trying to
you know determine uh a replica of that
uh you know fine scale model that one
can have outputs uh you know almost
equal right outputs almost equal right
and the Machinery they go through to do
that it depends upon uh if you want to
do physics base if you want to do a data
driven and so forth okay
all right so what is the approach that
we have taken in the past
okay the approach is there is the
classical approach of uh you know a
projection based model reduction and
that's basically if you have a uh an
equation like this can be a reservoir
simulation it can be the reservoir
equation right we assume that we can
project right this uh States large scale
system States into a much smaller
Subspace right here uh using this V
which we call projection right and we
can project this that's uh you know the
classical approach and we can get uh you
know a reducer modeling out of that okay
and that's the you know many many people
have have done that we have several
papers on that but there are issues with
that implementation it is that uh you
know the one one thing one look at this
is a nonlinear function uh and of course
uh being a nonlinear function one can uh
you know doesn't have a when you project
this you still have to go back to the
full scale system to actually solve the
system and there's somewhat being fixed
with the uh the discrete
interpolation or some kind of uh
interpolation in uh on that nonlinear
space right but the problem as well it
is that there is a second issue there is
no output information used on this uh on
this translation here okay so that's one
thing that we're going to try to fix
another you know projection based model
reduction is really nice you can get uh
you know really good uh you know
reduction and uh you know I haven't
tried yet LeBron myself and I know that
you guys have a uh a good understanding
of that but a projection based model
reduction per se it is not a robust way
of solving the problem why because uh
you know here is a you know
if you have a let's say a reservoir it's
a cartoon like with the wells here
there's ax dots what happens if you move
a well from a place to another place
your reducer model completely breaks
down
okay there's no way to you know at least
in the classical approach there's no way
to handle that the the dynamical system
is completely different okay of course I
mean and as well if you drill a new well
or if you open and close these Wells
things uh uh breaks down and the problem
is exactly how to handle these boundary
conditions right because if you have an
offline training process right and the
classical approach you know if you do uh
SPD right on the online approach the
boundary conditions are completely
different right so we somehow have to
some have a form of adaptivity to do
that and we worked a little bit on the
on that on the paper and many many years
ago with the yachina feneyev from the
math department that somehow you know
adaptively we you know try to solve you
know reconstruct that basis but it's
still you need a fast solver to
reconstruct the bases and back then you
use a multi-scale type of solver and you
know it's nice but uh you know if you're
gonna go and apply this uh for much
larger problems that may not be the the
way to go
okay so uh here's an example of a uh a
classical uh you know physics-based
model reduction applied to a hydraulic
fraction process with a couple flow
angiomechanics right
um if you only look at uh you know here
you have a well but two Wells actually
parallel Wells with a uh and we test it
out from 8 to 24 fractures here the 8 to
24 is uh how many fractures you have in
here and you take a class A take a
snapshots of pressures saturations and
uh
and when uh the
displacement sorry the the measurements
of the displacements and you go through
this physics space and you get a good
speed up here uh and you can see that as
more fracture that you get more speed up
that you get exactly because there is a
uh uh is overhead associated with the
process so the more
actually that you get of course there
will be a higher speed up on the process
as I mentioned
if we do some changes on this things
will break down and that's why we I I
always in my paper they say when it
works it works really well right and
there's still not robust yet for for
lots of tweaking and here and there okay
all right so so what the existing
solution that we are looking at and uh
what we're going through okay so many of
these things have already been you know
done in uh or been published right uh
pod game or tpwl dynamic decomposition
neural Nets uh e2c that we're going to
talk to explore a little bit more and uh
lifting by linearizations okay some of
them they have a good uh handling some
of them they have gaps right so what I'm
going to show to you in the next uh
maybe 20 minutes or so is a combination
of these methodologies okay in
particular you're going to show e2co
uh I'm gonna show something in
bilinarization that's basically the
title of the uh the um the the talk
today okay
all right so if you go back to the
reservoir equation right and the PD
equation you can write up a discretized
form right and and this discretized
forms can be written up on this
framework here that I call a a classical
uh system framework right where a b c d
can be our matrices and
they are not necessarily constant
matrices they are function of the time
right and that's part of the the
non-linear you know problem associated
with this these equations right but the
question is
if one can write this up these equations
by hand you solve the problem right it's
really hard to do that especially uh
because you have a very nonlinear
problem that you don't know how to you
got to go and get all these jacobians
and so forth inside the system so
building up this Matrix is a b c d uh it
is important and if you can do that
without accessing the the simulator code
um it would be really nice so the the
hypothesis here it is that one can you
estimate those matrices Buzz based upon
only a dynamic evolution of the state
and you know that it's possible it's
possible if you look at what's called
embedded to control okay and embedded to
control it is as follows if you have a
uh a system
um and you have a snapshots of your uh
you know simulation let's call this a x
you can go through an encoder decoder
framework and I'm going to show what I
mean by these transitions in a minute
right and you can get out of this A and
B information of that so it's a paper
and a couple of years ago that use that
for Reservoir simulation and we thought
well that's really nice but we have if
we don't have information about the
output so what we do with that output
right one can reconstruct the output by
going through a piece one equation
that's great but uh if you have a
optimizing things that are closing and
opening Wells that may not work too well
okay so what we've done we took that to
one next level and uh we developed a uh
the E to co and observe observe here
okay
um in the following way we now are
creating not only a b and then in that
uh in that uh you know equation here but
we're creating C and D as well as you go
and train this this network okay so
you're going create this network so the
uh just going a little bit into details
I mean the the network itself can it's
in the paper okay but um
uh one can uh no create a a network with
transitions input and out State and
output whereby one look at uh you know a
series of dance layers batch
normalization value and a output a b c
and d
okay that's really nice we tested uh you
know a small problem here with a
training with a uh this particular uh
you know we have several Wells and a
particular you know input to the system
right and uh you get a good uh really
nice uh output information here
um I can go into details later on if you
if you want me to go through this how we
actually implemented this but as far as
the training goes
now if you have a good implementation of
uh you know gpus in our case this is a
small system it took us 38 minutes right
now of course I mean if you go to some
bigger bigger problems then for training
purposes that might be uh much larger uh
timing for for training but the nice
thing is that if you compare the High
Fidelity simulation here on the left
with this e2co right at least uh
visually speaking uh you can say there's
a really good matching right but uh as
far as the matching the well rates
um that's even better right you can say
that uh you know the high fidelity
simulation here is the uh the black one
and the uh the green is the e2co and if
you look at uh the Reconstruction that's
called proposition one here the
Reconstruction of for using pisman
equation
um it's a little bit far off so we think
that our methodology uh it's a little
bit better than just reconstructing the
uh the uh the pisman equation right and
especially when you open and close Wells
right and then we we handle we actually
run some statistics so one can look at
this on the paper as well and uh e2cl
always get a little bit better you know
running this many many times I always
get a better
uh you know error as compared to the uh
just uh you know reconstructed by a
piecement equation okay we took this a
little bit farther and said well can we
do a 3D model can we do a bigger model
and the answer is yes but if you look at
uh you know 3D models that usually they
have a uh no active grid blocks right uh
the e2c or d2co cannot handle that in in
some ways because you need a uh you know
some chi-square architecture or a
rectangular architecture right but we
are able to handle this uh with a uh
partial convolution layers right and
they can explain later on if it needs to
but here is a solution for this uh AG
model
with a uh with the uh our etco
we have a paper in preparation that is
going to show all the uh demonstration
here and the timing so um hopefully that
will be published soon as well okay
all right so that's great uh I spent
maybe a half an hour or so to talk a
little bit about that but let me move on
to uh you know issues that we encounter
as doing e2co right and uh and one of
the issues was that exactly only
non-linearities right and uh as I said
many times you get uh you know things to
work many times you get things not to
work uh especially uh if you go from the
classical uh you know uh mod reduction
to a little bit on this e2co and e2co by
the way it's it's a it's a if you look
at the uh what the implementation is
actually a trajectory piecewise
implementation with a proper tagonal
decomposition embed into it so but the
the the proper terminal decomposition
you get on uh using this uh encoder
decoder framework right
so there's still some issues with
nonlinearities and one way that we saw
to solve the problem was to look back uh
what we've done
you know maybe six seven years ago on
writing up a uh uh the the the
non-linear equations uh into what's
called a bilinear form
okay back then
um we wrote this by linear form what I
mean by that if you have a full order
system here the same way that we had
before we can write this up into this by
linear form right here this body linear
form which can get us a little bit
better handling on the nonlinearities
the thing is that in when we publish the
paper we wrote that uh bilateralization
by hand okay and as you're going to see
there's no linearization or this
bi-linearization depend upon augmenting
the states right if you have States X to
be order of n right when we go to these
states uh here on the Berliner form you
are actually almost doubling the number
of states right and back then if you
look at the paper right
we are not able to solve much larger
problems I mean we had a very tall
example was very nice theoretically what
we wrote but we hit at that time a wall
say well we cannot uh proceed further
okay what happens in the last five six
years was the development of this uh
notion of the coupon operator right the
the the Deep neural net basic open
operator and I'm going to show you the
next slide what a basically common
operator and the coupon operator allows
you to go to you know this
binauralization in a much cheap cheaper
way okay and that's basically what we
are proposing we're proposing to go from
a uh this non-linear system through a
coupon operator writing it up as a body
linear form and then operating on this
body linear form and creating projectors
to do that
this model reduction step okay
of course this is not so easy right
otherwise uh we'll be really happy right
um and I'm going to show in the next uh
slides what uh what issues we encounter
doing that and how we actually fixed
some of the issues okay so but anyway so
the the idea is actually writing up uh
equipment operator to bilinarize the
system and then the projection uh on the
Fly using uh this projection matrices V
and PSI okay all right so
um common uh operator coupon theory is
not new
it's something that uh you know was
developed in the 30s
and basically it is uh uh trying to
write up this uh new set of coordinate
systems so that you can kind of somehow
linearize the the uh this system right
so you write this up into the higher
Dimension State space that you can see a
linearization out of that so you hear an
original manifold and um thanks to the
papers here by Nathan and and cuts and
Brunton they're moved on from the uh the
the the the theory only the theory to
actually something more that's really
efficient for computation okay
so we can go from the original manifold
to a flat manifold using this equipment
uh Theory okay and the classical example
here uh not spending too much time is
actually looking at this ode if you have
this ode which is non-linear if you can
find this operator PSI here
um whatever the operator is right and
introduce this operator into your
dynamical system okay one can look at
the new equation here in the the bottom
right as a linear operator okay it's a
linear operator so that's basically the
idea right but finding this function
finding this function it is the the hard
thing and that's what uh you know
prevented us from moving on from this
paper
to to do something else with that right
we didn't know how to do it right
um
so so how does it how does it work okay
so imagine that you have a a full
simulation here right and uh you run the
simulator uh using your equations
whatever whatever you have and then you
save up these states okay save up the
snapshots of the states okay so what one
does for determine the coupon operator
it is as follows you take these
snapshots you run these snapshots
through a series of networks here deep
learning networks okay
and not only that you have a uh encoding
process here that you go from a high
order space to low order space kind of
doing doing a projection right if you
look at this encoding it's basically
doing a projection okay so you you train
this network using the states such as
that you find the coupon operator
but at the same time you find the
projection matrices PSI and fees here
that we we're going to use to project
the system okay of course you can look
at this is just a locking process you
can do petroval working that's the same
type of uh of experimentation right but
one goes to this network and train this
network and find this fee and find these
projection matrices that you have now a
set of coordinates in the Latin space
and the a matrix is actually read read
up directly from this network
okay so let me so that's basically the
the coupon operator process
right all right so let me uh show what
we implemented this uh
we start up with a very simplistic case
with a buck Levert right which uh highly
lonely and non-linear in some sense and
has issues especially you're going to
try to apply this into the physics
informed neuron at framework right so
here's our equation
um
if as I mentioned if there's some work
on the on the trying to do this in the
physics in form neural NET Framework
right and of course I mean the classical
approach for handling uh in a bug
collaborate is to add up this uh
artificial viscosity for stability
purposes right so if you add up this
stability
parameter for
you can guarantee stability of these uh
this uh book leverage right
this uh you know additional of stability
has been solved by uh uh I think having
another another slide it's a fox and uh
and a chalape that developed some uh you
know how to actually introduce this
artificial viscosity right using the pin
but here we try to solve using
um what we call a we turn this into a
learner learnable parameter so I'm not
going to do out too much that's not the
point here the point is that uh you know
the the bottle average uh has stability
issues one can fix using a learnable
parameter learnable viscosity all right
as you can see here okay we can see
there's a uh you know by using adaptive
learner learnable viscose you can
actually uh
stabilize the system but
the using uh the use of coupon operator
can also stabilize the system okay so
here's the Here's the the the the
solution okay so if you use a uh you
know varying battery conditions using
this framework for the coupon operator
right one can actually stabilize the
solution of this uh book leverage okay
so that gave us a little bit of Hope on
how to explore this for much uh for
single phase to phase and move to phase
flow right and that's the solution here
and by the way so the if you look at
just the the Buckle average uh I know
the comparing uh you know this may not
be a fair comparison given that our
proxy was done in a different framework
into different uh you know platform but
just uh look at if you have a thousands
of simulations of book elaborate it may
take 1.2 hours in our case uh using this
coupon process it takes uh 2.3 seconds
so just to keep this in into perspective
okay
okay so uh now uh going a little bit
more for two phase flow right uh we
apply this for uh uh you know going for
two phase flaws here with the two
producers and one injector right
um
and let me show a little bit what the uh
the issues were developing this for a
much larger problem okay as you're gonna
see
um there are actually not only five oh
this is part of the the training process
right I think I forgot to mention right
how to actually train this right uh you
train by base Upon A introducing loss
functions into the process right to
guarantee some some matching of the
states and outputs and other things okay
um as you're gonna see the process is
not yet uh efficient in the falling way
you still have lots of loss functions
that we have to deal with right and not
only five as you written up here but you
have actually the whole framework uh is
that actually eight loss functions and
we don't know what to do with them uh
you know to be honest right how do you
combine them up into a much much less
number of loss functions but the the
idea here is is that on the training
process right uh one introduced a loss
function for the out encoder right that
we wanna uh you know
match up the state we also want to match
up the uh the the coupon State and Latin
space right and uh we want to match up
the prediction in X and and other things
as well okay so those are the loss
functions that one has to guarantee to
uh to make this student to work okay one
issue that we actually
we hit a wall I mean there was a
Marcellus de la Cuates uh here at a m uh
a year and a half ago we hit the wall
say well we cannot do it why
because again coming back to the problem
of having controls and output right if
you write this up there for the coupon
function for the reservoir simulation
equation and it's always a term here
right and uh it's a simplistic uh you
know differentiation here but there's a
term
there is a non-linear in control that we
know how we don't know how to handle
that
okay so we started for nonlinear system
we could potentially discover the the
the coupon operator but there is always
going to be a non-linear function here
that cannot be discoverable okay so at
that time we hit the wall like maybe a
year and a half two years ago and all of
the sudden Marcelo was very diligent and
found a solution okay and the solution
was the following there was a paper
here 2021 that talks about the following
if you have a system a nonlinear system
that is control a fine
and what I mean control fine if you can
pull out the control u in this
particular form
okay the system can be bilinearized
okay that's the paper that's basically
what uh the paper tells if you have a
system that is control controller fine
right the system can be bilinearized and
how do you buy linearize you apply this
to the control I mean there's a process
here in place but basically what you
find instead of finding just a matrix
you find n and B Matrix in this way a n
and B Matrix right here okay
so that's exactly what we've done we
took that and we buy linearized based
upon the guarantee that one can do that
given the fact that uh Reservoir
equations are in this control of fun way
okay so here's the solution
applying this to a control a fine
perspective and bilinarize the with the
controls here's the the solution
uh using to you know again uh you know
at least uh from uh you know inspection
you can see that uh uh the the proxy
model can handle really well the the
saturation fronts and everything
especially for varying wear rates
okay very rare rates
yeah but that not necessarily the the
whole story because you might end up
with a a matrix that it may not be
necessarily stable okay and that's what
I meant that there are lots of a loss
functions that we added up to make this
a little bit more robust okay and one
way that we handle this uh a matrix not
to be stable we basically said instead
of let's let's uh the the a matrix is a
small Matrix right it comes in the Latin
it's formed the Latin space so it's a
small Matrix so we can afford to
calculate the eigenvalues and what we do
if we have eigenvalues that are uh
outside of the unit circle right we clip
them off we clip them off right and
luckily that didn't happen too often but
there was a particular loss function
that we introduced uh to clip that uh or
to to guarantee that you'd have a able
solution for the a matrix
okay again remember what I mentioned we
have too many loss functions that we we
don't know yet how to combine them
together okay but anyway so uh if the
system are stable then they can see that
uh matching the results and the Well
locations are really good okay with
errors uh you know point four percent
point one percent uh for water
saturation and pressures so we really
give us uh hope to do that okay
now
the second issue that we encounter right
is as follows that's great
we can do that and I'm I'm about to stop
here in a maybe a couple more minutes
that's great we can find this a n and
B's but that depend upon how actually
initialize the system okay so you're
given a seed for that training uh you
know it's a stochastic process it
depends upon the how we actually train
you may get uh not so good results okay
so
we we Marcelo had a second uh you know
uh contribution here was as follows why
don't we use what we know already which
is a DMD right to initialize with a very
few snapshots we initialize a n and B
given already the the you know proper
snapshots of the the system okay so
given proper snapshots of the system
okay we can initialize the a n and B
okay using this idea of bilinear mode
decomposition okay so if you look at the
paper one can look at bilinarizations
right and one can uh you know re create
in the very uh efficient way a very uh
initial value for a and b okay yeah I'm
not going to go into details on DMD by
linear DMD but one can do that and uh so
what we call a stepwise training process
we St we we train the alt encoder then
we create we're using a few snapshots of
the states we initialize a n and B and
then we with that initial States and B
we train uh all together uh for the
final result okay and as a comparison
here again one uh simulation 45 seconds
for that model uh and if you have a 320
and that was the the data set that we
had it took us four hours in the mrst
but as opposed to 40 seconds in our our
framework with a really good stable
results and robust results okay so some
remarks here and then I'll close down
um things are uh you know
entirely uh buodanized States snapshots
and uh you know we add up output
information
um and we're able to reconstruct the
surrogate uh doing uh you know this idea
of uh
binaryization okay one thing that we're
working on at the moment it is as
follows uh we can you know if you look
at the control theory right the balance
truncation it is actually a better model
reduction uh you know one can for at
least for linear system right balance
vacation it is the way to go for if you
have input and output that's what our
main objective so what we are working on
is actually translating this in this
framework into this balanced location
framework okay and I'm gonna skip some
of this okay and the balance location
framework is actually a
a something that looks at uh
controllability and observability right
um it's really good for uh linear
systems and basically it translates to
find this controllability functions uh
piece and observability functions cues
okay that uh
identifies states that are easy to
control and observer observations that
are difficult to to measure okay so if
you put this into two perspective right
they're called grammians right and uh we
if you look at the equations one look at
how to calculate those gramins right but
in the end it turns out that
for our case for taking that uh
framework for doing balanced truncation
it's just a matter of adding warm or
loss functions okay warm or loss
function which is a minimizing the trace
of these two equations here okay
um and we have a paper coming up that
talks about that right but basically uh
that's the uh the solution here using
balance truncation okay uh and one can
say that you get uh you know really good
results with balance truncation uh
anyway so that input output perspective
that can match really well input and
output
okay so let me just conclude here
um we propose uh you know transformation
for a non-linear system to more amenable
form Etc of piecewise linearizations but
in a form uh as I said we have used
several loss functions too many to be
honest right uh uh and uh hopefully that
we will be able to fix this in the near
future but uh the the nice thing is that
uh we have the addition of the output
information which may be really
important for some some uh you know
implementation in some applications okay
uh as we speak uh you know uh Marcelo
had graduated so I have another student
now taking days up uh one Arch and doing
this for CCS so we're testing out to uh
implementation for carbon capture uh so
hopefully we're gonna do that and uh
have another student looking at
possibilities of you using transfer
learning when boundary condition changes
okay so exactly when you when you open
and close uh Wells when you move Well
locations how we actually if you want to
do optimization for or well location
optimizations how actually one can
handle this into our framework
and finally uh as I mentioned I haven't
tested uh libron myself
um and I'm eager to you know get my
hands dirty and get maybe some of this
implementation into into Libra so with
that I'm gonna finish here acknowledge
some of my uh collaborators as I
mentioned in the beginning and some of
the funding here
um and uh I'm open for questions and
answers and anything that you wanna know
from the from the uh from the
implementation thanks so much
yeah thanks for a wonderful talk about
the Gooding we truly look forward to the
collaboration of using libram on the
digital twin especially in the soft
surface applications yes uh now we don't
have any questions in the chat room yet
um if the audience have a question
please raise your hand or feel free to
amuse yourself
so uh while we're waiting um I I may ask
some questions so um I'm curious about
the potential challenges of applying
say the ec2o approach to more complex or
real realistic resinful models like uh
compositional reservers or black oil
models so we'll also encoder be very
difficult to train in such large State
spaces
yes that's actually one of the uh the
main issues I mean the um uh the
the training process is actually the
main issue right I mean uh it's not
necessarily the training process but the
the computational time involved in this
training process right uh we are testing
some of uh of our framework for larger
problems using the high performance
Computing here at the a m
um and in the it takes several hours to
do that to do the training right so
that's uh something we're looking at the
ways to reduce that timing
um but we I don't have a uh I don't have
a a silver bullet to tell you uh what to
do right
um yeah I see so uh just curious I well
do you think the ec2 or ec2o uh
framework will work if we simply use
linear compression in the state space
because I mean it is more easy to uh
yeah
so if you look at uh uh you know linear
compression meaning uh like doing an SVD
yes yes right yes yes
um yes and no right I mean uh
the outer encoder is actually a
is an SVD framework if you will right I
mean it's uh it's a pod like right and
uh
we we is on the the classical approach
uh using pod we've done that and we we
showed that we can do that but again
um
it has robustness issues right and uh
the deciding on a number of uh you know
redis ordered States
is not necessarily if you follow the
recipe like you know get the energy
function and the cut do a cut off
that doesn't work for for some reason
that doesn't work for uh much more
complicated problem right so I I believe
there's there's a there's a much better
way to to do that that I I don't know
right
okay
um
we have a question I can ask questions
you know the frame of you introduced
like first to the auto encoder and then
fit the latent space data into you know
there's a specific form of DMD
um in the later part of your talk right
I I was wondering how you
parameterize the framework maybe I
missed that but probably you explain
that because you you do have some
parameter to tweak right I mean there's
a source locations or
um
you know whatever the boundary
conditions or initial condition whatever
you're changing that your model has to
be robust in parameter change right how
you deal with that
mistake the the the things that I
presented here uh we have a fixed uh
fixed system
right
um what I haven't shown here is actually
the the uh the parametrization right
um we we don't have a uh we are working
with uh you you may know uh Jim Ragusa
yeah yeah so so we we are working with
John Ragusa to actually do this
interpolation uh the parameterization
interpolation right
um and the the in the classical way of
model reduction for for at least for
Reservoir simulation uh one can
parameterize the um know the Well
locations by looking at distances and we
we had a paper you know a couple of
years ago on doing that uh it works uh
somewhat uh well right but it's not it's
not robust again right but we are hoping
that this collaboration with General
Ragusa will lead us to a little bit
better better way of uh you know uh the
interpolation yeah he he has he has
published some parametric DMD Primo
recently but you you may also want to
check our recent paper on latent space
Dynamics identification papers I can
send two of those and both of them
talking up talking about the uh the
parameterization and also you know when
you do the parameterizations you need to
sample
um to to to decide where
um in the parameter space you need to
generate the data so all those things
things
we'll be glad to take a look at yes yeah
yeah I can follow that to you yeah sure
okay yeah uh it sounds good so I didn't
see any more questions so um if there's
a case less vein started building again
for sharing his Excellence research with
us
thanks so much thanks for the invitation
and I'll be glad to to collaborate more